Hello, this is Spencer McKenna from Full Solutions.
I'm calling to schedule a meeting to discuss your marketing strategy.
Hello, Miss McKenna! I'm Josh.
Thank you for calling.
Setting up a meeting sounds like a good idea.
Great!
I'm glad you're still interested in setting up a meeting.
Are you available some afternoon this week?
Hmmm, I'm a little busy in the afternoon this week.
How about a morning meeting?
Unfortunately, a morning meeting is not possible this week.
In that case, how does 1 p.m. this Friday sound?
Okay, then I will schedule the meeting for 1 p.m. this Friday, June 25th.
How does that sound?
That sounds fine.
Where will the meeting be held?
Great.
The meeting location will be at our offices...
...so you can meet the whole team who will work on the marketing strategy.
Great.
I look forward to meeting the whole team.
I look forward to meeting you then.
I will send you a follow-up email to confirm the meeting.
Thank you.
Please let me know if you have any questions before the meeting.
I will.
Goodbye.
Thank you.